tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fa vj e oggi ho il sorriso a
13.000 denti perché stiamo per iniziare
un gameplay che volevo fare tipo da da
quando avevo 6 anni no seriamente volevo
fare da un sacco di tempo comunque però
non l'ho mai fatto perché non lo so mi
sono svegliato stamattina ho detto che
insomma questo non l'ho ancora fatto
perché quindi ragazzi videogame in
questione di stanley parabola parabola
di stanley che non è una roba di gesù di
stanley prima di cominciare ragazzi
siccome è sottotitolato in italiano
non sto tradurre io a voce quindi
dovreste leggere se sapete leggere nel
caso andate un po a scuola e poi
guardate questo video
beh ragazzi cominciamo è una roba seria
fatemi concentrare lo stesso story of an
di stanley danny welbeck
[Musica]
a carlo con il singolo è rimasto anni a
cliccare a caldo senza mangiare né
dormire vabbè ragazzi nostra storia [ __ ]
e veramente [ __ ] l'unica roba che non ho
capito il perché ci è rimasto a vita
sosta sedia cerveno sono io quando edito
i video e rega più o meno la stessa cosa
che bella ambientazione ragazzi mi piace
troppo ma dobbiamo andare nella sala di
fondi esterni che devo entrare in quella
sinistra quindi ovviamente non entrerò
in quella sinistra mi dirà qualcosa si
loro snob pure kwait del meeting room
and standing still pensavo mi dicesse
qualcosa di peggio pensavo mi mandasse a
cagare ragazzi ma non è successo per la
prima porta alla mia sinistra questa qui
ma se io non la prendesse mi facessi
ogni volta i cazzi miei
grazie
sono così anch'io e tranquillo alla
madonna ho visto stanze così grande in a
chi importa le moto
ecco che il figlio non ci credo va bene
dai giovani ovviamente ho saltato dalla
piazza fatto sta fondendo in tutti i
modi possibili regala bellissimo stanley
works ubuntu però mistica ragazzi cosa
devo fare della mia vita se mistica
quest'uomo misti chi sa fare la cosa
sbagliata devi dirmi di entrare in
quella blu se voi che entri in quella
rossa cioè devi fare il contrario
non ce la faccio ragazzi in sala capsule
santos todd stern e what cruda red door
su chiami il gelato esperienze 23
milioni caring problemi ha evidenziato
rossa perché se no non lo capivo grazie
e grazie ad esso si che che che ho
capito sicuro ma ero convinto che ci
fosse ma io ci vado ci vado ve ne frega
niente
ovunque dove non mi dice lui è
bellissimo e se io mi masturbarsi sulle
stanze vuote che problemi ai feedback
questa è difficile rega ci vado posso
sono entrato in quella giusta stavolta è
per una under sto chiude a no ciao mia
speranza
sì penso di sì sì no no no va bene vai
tranquillo
ok ok devo fermare il bambino si ma è la
grafica di questo gioco non è così bella
però come funzionava bene
[Musica]
ragazzi mi sento una persona felice mi
bastano 10 secondi per capire che un
gioco di merda zio possiamo devo farlo
per forza per quattro ore
perché vi mancano circa 3 ore e 59
minuti
io lo lascio per fare lega già posso più
fare è morto a basse grazie fra the
famous ma lui preso ma nello schema
giusto i giochi di qualcun altro che
gioco mi spara a kit mario ma no ma no
fa perché oramai crafty ha creato sta
roba dategli una medaglia in mezzo che
bello guarda bene il mio lavoro d'arte e
prova vergogna
i ragazzi gras ai fini apre la porta al
suo gentilissimo meravigliosa e mi sto
venendo we must be built around di
diamanti sta dicendo sul serio stiamo
giocando a mike rann le torce non lo
fate zio da temine mandatemi le torce
tipo che new game come nuovo gioco da
fermo che sta facendo
[Risate]
vabbè
usciamo se imparasse zio siamo in portal
che non è proprio minecraft però è figo
se avessi scelto le altre porte sarei
finito qua lo stesso cioè non ho capito
è bellissimo è un rompicapo thinking mar
grazie grazie di finocchio che è
difficile non so come ho fatto a
risolverlo
grazie sono buttato un po dio siamo
tornati dovranno prima ragazzi sono
tornati in stanley para non ci siamo
passati da dada minecraft a porta alla
stanley parabola in tre secondi
bellissimo mi scusi signor narratore
dove sta
siamo finiti non so dove dal 3 tutto
buio bellissimo ma questa è una parte
non scoperta del gioco ci siamo finiti
in una parte che non era prevista allora
c'è una luce cioè non lasciate quale
orami stanza 427 dovrebbe essere qua
dietro in teoria ma è tutto spento e non
quindi non so dove devo andare proprio
cioè mandò fuori fund e fuori buon gusto
leading man and some store e pop up
cisco ma sono tornati nostro caffè che
ho capito che questo era uno dei finali
freddo c'è veramente ho fatto il finale
è quello tragico quello brutto brutto in
giù duro nice left ok allora entrò in
quella sinistra zio ti ascolto faccio
finta di che sei un genio permesso sto
facendo le cose giuste sono un bravo
ragazzo adesso faccio tutto giusto tutto
e mi chiedevo snodo single
ok andiamo nella stanza del capo ragazzi
cosa vi devo dire
mi fa strano perché adesso mi chiederà
di andare su e invece io andrò
giovamento grace steve jobs ragazze
difficile seguire quello che mi che
vabbè dai mi farò forza prova prof ci
prova è perché povero questione di
indole veline da fare le cose che non mi
dicono di fare cioè l'opposto però vabbè
non c'era anche la segretaria fantastico
permesso madonna che ufficio grado zero
bush ha preso boss e ben keeping from
her hands
remember to hate 2 capito grazie
italiano non lo potrei sapere però
esatto pulsanti a caso proprio entra
quindi nel suo passaggio segreto quale a
questo che bello che culo ragazzi avevo
tirato a caso ma ho azzeccato
complimenti grazie mille sta diventando
strano sempre più strano mentre scendeva
sempre unica di sentirsi in maniera
strana fa veramente a me scappa solo da
kacar e poi vabbè ma dove siamo
ma è impianto controllo della mente
escape di cose non c'è una scritta
agosto scritto uscita però vabbè è
sempre più difficile scegliere quello
che mi dice di fare però per ora faccio
quello che mi dice di fare poi più
avanti farò l'uscita permesso mi sembra
di essere in matrix che cos'è sta roba
place that the sun le cure e cibo ai
colleghi di stanley wells tutti
monitorati
ma non c'è nessuno regala dov'è dov'è il
mio schermo
fammi capire uno che sa si accerta ski
sulla tastiera per anni a caso se ne fa
un paio di domande vabbè si rifiutava di
credersi deficiente la domanda non è
neanche quella ma come mai ha continuato
per due anni a premere tasti aned con
lui altri sport began quindi devo
distruggerlo ecco qua si gioca bene alla
playstation avessi la connessione per la
morbidità e premiamo non oso pensare che
cosa succederebbe se premessi home
invece che off però premiamo ho seguito
alla lettera quello che mi ha detto non
ho fatto niente di diverso
[Musica]
platini
wise insurance co sì ma sono solo morto
sei successi
difficile dove cazzo siamo un sacco di
soffrono news il commando è la libertà
quella miglia che bello stelle effetti
don augusto e appunto se io non volevo
fare un sacco di altre cose provengono
gli uccelli per dar senso di libertà
hanno messo gli uccelli grandi
grandissimi che devo mettere piede giù
dalla stanza praticamente mi ha aiutato
davvero narratore non pensavo questo
invece il finale buono giustamente c'è
quello più di prima a labro tutto questo
a bangkok ragazzi è stato è stato
veramente figo solo che ci sono non so
quanti finali possibile se non andrò a
cercare una cosa su wikipedia perché
credo che ce ne siano tipo troppi perché
c'è veramente ci sono troppe possibilità
di fuga continua nel prossimo episodio
ragazzi è sorta di esperimento perché è
un po diversa dai video che faccio di
solito però spero che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi perché finalmente un gioco che
posso fare anche col braccio ingessato
che non perdo l'anima fantastico
comunque sia ragazzi con quello che
l'episodio spero che vi sia piaciuto
come senso se vi è piaciuto al suo
documento è un mi piace un mi piace se
anche voi fate l'esatto contrario di
quello che vi dice alla gente perché una
cosa è una mia caratteristica in realtà
sempre anche a scuola
urlavo durante le elezioni come
l'esorcista se non servirsi di sky ci
vediamo al prossimo vinto dai ragazzi